I know they can't be here with us today
but if Todd and Julie could share a
message with the world what do you think
they'd want them to know you know I
think they'd want folks to know that
they are the same people they've always
been that they didn't do these things
and they're going to fight to get their
name cleared
your clients Todd and Julie Chrisley
they surrendered to begin serving their
prison sentences I'm curious about their
mental States how are they doing you
know Todd and Julie are both very
faithful people they're very strong and
I think they're taking that strength
that inner strength and that Faith with
them to prison you know it's a tough
time for any family facing something
like this but they know what the road
ahead looks like and they know they have
an opportunity to appeal their case
that's what they're doing and they're
optimistic about those results
so I believe there was a change Julie
originally was going to serve her time
in Florida but she's since shifted to a
Lexington Kentucky facility why the
change yeah that's a question for the
Bureau of Prisons folks get designated
by
um the Department of Justice the subset
the Bureau of Prisons and that's up to
them ultimately it may have to do with
space it may have to do with issues at
the facility in Florida but it's nothing
that we can tell you what are Todd and
Julie's biggest concerns about this
journey that lies ahead I think the
biggest concern that we've been
discussing recently is making sure that
the world knows sort of how they ended
up in this place that the caricature of
them is these sort of greedy villains
that the government's tried to paint is
just not accurate and I think making
sure the world knows a broader you know
picture in a broader story as to what
led to this case how this case proceeded
and ultimately what put them in prison
we've been listening to the various
Chrisley podcasts leading up into this
day and there were a lot of comments
that were made where they were even
seemingly up until the last minute
optimistic for a miracle there is that
possibility of my husband and I being
separated but there's a difference
between my husband and I being separated
for a period of time and having to say
goodbye forever if
there is a miracle that happens then
guess what you're gonna come on the next
week I think they're optimistic and let
me be clear I think that optimism is
well placed this trial was riddled with
heirs and we expect the appeals court to
see that have they been able to be in
touch with their family are they able to
rely on each other during such a trying
time
you know I think that the family has
plans for how they're going to
communicate and I expect they'll follow
through on those plans and the federal
prisons each one has a different
visitation schedule you are allowed to
visit with family and again this is a
close family and they're obviously going
to spend time visiting with one another
their ten-year-old Chloe we hold her
you know Chloe's 10 years old and I know
that she's on TV at certain times but
outside of that I think it's probably
that Chloe best of Chloe be allowed to
grow up as any other 10 year old would
you know one day they're watching
cartoons one day they're upset about the
meal I don't know you know how Chloe
feels about her lunch today but you know
being a 10 year old is hard no matter
what circumstances are
um let me ask you a little bit about
restitution we understand that they owe
17 million dollars in restitution how do
they plan to bounce back from that well
again that's presuming that that
restitution is going to be upheld we
think it's likely not to be why is that
well because the way the court
calculated it was incorrect I mean
there's a number of issues as I said in
this case that are likely to be reversed
on appeal
started serving their sentence about you
know repaying that restitution the main
focus and the main plan right now is to
make sure that the errors of the trial
court are reversed by the appeals court
going in day one are is the fight to get
out already started
absolutely I think that anybody who's
facing a prison term and is in a
contested case with the government is
going to try to fight uh you know well
before they end up behind those bars and
will continue to fight when they are are
the Chrisleys exhausted they've been
fighting for a long time you know I
think it it's one of these things
exhaustion or non-exhaustion the life
you have is what is what you're facing
it's sort of like if you have cancer
cancer is a difficult long thing to move
through so is a criminal prosecution
that's an analogy that I often use to
describe this to folks who aren't
lawyers I mean even if you have cancer
it's a difficult thing to face but your
judge you know your your doctor May tell
you you've got a good prognosis I mean
here I think ultimately they do have a
good prognosis to be able to get out of
prison but they have to take a step at a
time we've been listening to these
Chrisley podcasts like I mentioned
before and they've been very adamant
that they don't have faith in the
judicial system now to hear that they do
have faith in the system that they are
optimistic that an appeal could be the
end result talk to me about that shift
in mentality quality well it's the
difference between saying what happened
to us is wrong and I don't have faith
that it it shouldn't have happened in
the first place and then having some
faith that ultimately the truth of what
happened to you will be revealed as the
process continues but there are
different players at each step in a
criminal prosecution you've got the
prosecutors who bring a case you've got
the jury and the judge who tries the
case then you've got an appeals court
that's purpose is to review what that
court that prior court has done those
are different people and you can believe
that you are sort of harmed at the lower
levels and be hopeful that that will
stop when you move on along the appeal
what is the strongest tenant of the
appeal that makes you guys confident
that this all could be reversed I think
there's two things I mean I think the
very beginning of this case was an
unconstitutional search by the Georgia
Department of Revenue this Court's
already found that was unconstitutional
and it should have stopped the whole
case in its tracks that didn't happen
and that's certainly one of the things
we're pursuing on appeal the second
piece is one of the IRS officers who
testified about whether the Chrisleys
had paid certain taxes that's certainly
we think affected the jury and we
believe it'll be a basis for a new trial
we've heard Todd talk about making a
documentary we're at a much better place
um you know with new show content that's
going to be coming out that's going to
be giving you a whole new perspective of
the Chrisley family the documentary
that's being that we're working on right
now is going to be very Talent what do
you know about this documentary and the
message that the Chrisley family wants
to now show the world yeah I don't have
any details about the documentary uh I
can just tell you that there is there is
a story there about what they've been
through the past year or two that hasn't
been told you think there is a story
there I mean what do you think could be
in a documentary that might ultimately
vindicate them
well you know look again as I said
before this case started uh because an
officer with the Georgia Department of
Revenue went into the Chrisley's
property without a warrant pretended to
have a warrant and seized all their
stuff that sort of government overreach
and government's conduct started on day
one has continued throughout the
prosecution we have the kids on our
hearts the adult children and the minor
children
um what kind of strain has this put on
the family and ultimately how are they
going to Prevail through this all look
any family who faces a loved one going
to prison
um it's a very difficult challenge
that's true for this family but they're
strong they're faithful and I think
they'll continue in in that Way Forward